My name is Sami. I'm a restorative dentist
located in Southern California
and the owner of a
dental-educational channel
called Smile Influencers.
One tooth has a broken front tooth,
another tooth has a cavity
underneath an old crown,
and the third tooth has a broken filling,
and they all need to be fixed.
This case shows a broken
tooth on a mannequin.
Here, I'm using a thin diamond burr
that I use to create a 45-degree bevel
onto the tooth's surface.
The white stuff you
see here is Teflon tape
that I apply to the adjacent teeth
in order to protect the adjacent teeth
from the chemicals that I'm about to use.
The blue stuff that I'm using
is phosphoric acid etchant,
which essentially prepares
the tooth for bonding.
I make sure to wash off
the etchant thoroughly
in order to decrease the likelihood
of postoperative sensitivity.
The clear stuff that I'm
applying is a bonding agent
that I apply to the prepared tooth surface
and a little bit beyond.
I am curing the tooth
with an LED curing light,
which essentially polymerizes
any light-cured resin-based composites.
The blue putty that you see here
is a hydrophilic VPS impression material.
It is a guide that helps us in many cases.
Here, you can see us using composite resin
packed in incremental layers
to replace that missing tooth structure
and hopefully create a
filling that is very strong.
And a lot of these have different colors
that allow us to pick a shade
that closely matches our patient's teeth.
We also have different composite resins
that have different
translucency properties,
different opaque properties,
and this allows us to create a filling
that looks as natural as possible.
In this particular case,
since it's on a typodont,
we're just using one shade
to give you an example
of how to build up that
missing tooth structure.
After, I use a series of disks
that go from coarse to fine
to polish the filling, to
make sure there's no ledges,
and make sure that it's
as smooth as possible.
Now, when patients break their teeth,
it can be due to a variety of causes.
Trauma. Let's say you get into a fight
and someone punches you.
Falling down onto a hard
surface like concrete.
Anytime you put a strong
force onto your front teeth,
you can put it in jeopardy.
This tooth has a crown with an access hole
in the middle of it.
And there is a large
cavity that's developing
underneath that hole.
Crowns are very strong,
and they're typically
bonded onto the tooth.
And one of the safest
ways to remove a crown
is by using a little bit of leverage
to take the crown off.
I use a variety of large diamond burrs
in order to clean the
majority of the tooth cavity.
And at the very end, I
use a round carbide burr
that runs at a slower speed
in order to get the very
last bits of the cavity.
Bonding agent is then used.
We use a microbrush to apply
the bonding agent onto the tooth.
Core Paste is a composite resin system
that has a high compressive strength,
and it replaces a lot of
the lost tooth structure.
And we use an LED curing light to cure
the outermost layer of the Core Paste,
although it will also
naturally harden over time.
Here we are fabricating an
acrylic temporary crown.
We use temporary cement called TempBond
to place our temporary
crown onto the tooth.
This essentially maintains the space
until our lab technician finishes
fabricating a new dental crown.
Typically, cavities form
from poor oral hygiene,
maybe not brushing or
flossing the right way
or having a diet that's high in sugar.
This tooth has a broken filling
with a large cavity developing
between the filling and
their natural tooth.
In order to clean the decay out,
I first have to remove
the existing filling.
And in this particular case,
I'm using a diamond burr
to remove all of the old composite resin.
After that's removed, I
use a round carbide burr.
That's used on a slower speed to make sure
that I remove any infected dentin
or areas where there is a cavity present
until we have nice
healthy tooth structure.
In this particular case,
I'm using a bonding agent
called Clearfil SE Bond.
The primer and bond essentially
prepare the tooth surface
for the application
of our composite resin filling material
in order for the filling material
to successfully adhere.
This is called flowable resin.
It's less viscous
compared to other resins,
but it does a great job at sealing margins
and preventing postoperative sensitivity.
Packable composite resins
are highly viscous resins
that contain a high volume
of filler particles,
which gives them a stiff consistency.
At the very end, we are adjusting
the shape of the filling
in order to make the
occlusion of the patient
feel as natural as possible.
We're hoping that when our patient moves
left and right, front and back
that there is no interference
between the patient's motions
and the new filling that's in place.
I always tell my patients
that there are things
that you can do to protect your teeth,
like brushing and flossing
in the morning and at night.
Avoid dangerous habits
like opening packages with your teeth,
because although our
teeth are very strong,
they can break, and we
want to be very careful
and conscientious about
what we put in our mouth.